so peter thiel
billionaire libertarian a guy who was
one of the first
investors on facebook he put a half a
million dollars on facebook
he has amassed a 5 billion
dollar fortune in tax-free roth ira
count now if you don't know how roth
iras work different than the ira
you put money into an ira it's pre-tax
money you get a write-off every year but
at the end of it say you're
you're putting 4 500 every year to an
ira 30 years later you got half a
million dollars you take that half a
million dollars out
you will pay taxes on the half a million
dollars the roth ira you put money
after taxes into the roth and then
eventually you're making tax-free money
you decide to take the money out after
59 and a half
great you don't pay any taxes so how is
he raised
and increases account to five billion
dollars that's the question this is a
business insider story paypal co-founder
peter thiel
has managed to grow a tax-free
retirement account worth less
less than 2 000.99 to 5 billion
today according to a report from
propublica the roth ira was created by
congress in 1997 as a way to
for middle class americans he's
definitely not middle class to save for
a retirement dependent
of their employer retirement account
initially had two thousand dollars per
year contribution limit today the
contribution limit is six thousand
dollars americans
that make more than 140 000 per year are
unable to contribute to the account
that's because the tax treatment of a
roth ira is so beneficial to its user
that it allows
after tax money to compound for decades
in the stock market and then b withdrawn
tax free as long as the owner is 59 and
a half years old
thiel grew his fortune by using his roth
ira account to invest in early state
startups
which translated to massive windfalls
when those successful companies went
public
years later from there thiel was able to
use that windfall to invest in more
early stage companies
within his roth ira account now worth
five billion dollars
thoughts mary go ahead a similar story
on one of the other paypal founders did
the same thing
and i think that that's why you're
hearing for a lot of calls for
we should limit the benefit right now
the numbers are out there like two
million dollars should be the limit
threshold of what you can benefit
and the other aspect of this that's
really interesting is
you get the step up basis when you pass
it on to your heirs which is another
thing that they're trying to poke they
want the
benefit to stop at death it's just a
difficult thing to do because
you know peter thiel was in a position
where he had the ability to invest in
real early startups do it through the
roth ira and then the explosive growth
over
i think you started this you know over
20 years ago that explosive growth over
time
you know that's how you reach these
enormous numbers so
you know i watch cnbc all the time and
this is like the number one story on
cnbc right now like how the hell
did this happen so if you're not
familiar with the roth ira i'm a huge
fan of it
right so what i tell people is if you're
going to start investing start investing
long-term buy and hold if you work for a
company especially
a company that has a match with a 401k
that's a great option
free money it's a match ira that's
another option
but if you want to kind of do something
outside your company or if you're an
independent contractor
or if you don't if your company doesn't
have a match or 401k a roth ira is an
amazing option i've been telling our
friend eric galera to get a roth ira for
about a year now
and he's like yeah maybe next week all
right anyway get started that's the best
way you don't say the best eric listen
to this listen to the guy
adam pure so you know they said the best
day to plant the tree is 20 years ago
the next best day is today so
roth ira i started a roth ira in 2008
right after the great recession i had no
clue about investing i had no clue about
a 401k i could barely spell 401k
i remember i started taking my company
match well you know how to spell pen 15
though i do
i do i just learned today what pen 15
meant i didn't know what until you and
david taught me today
okay go ahead keep going so i started a
roth ira and i started a 401 can i
started investing that
that way now here's the catch the roth
ira is so good
that they only allow certain people to
um contribute right so i remember when i
was first starting i wasn't making 120
grand whatever the number was
140. it was amazing so it was 140 grand
now i'm making a little bit more than
that so i can't contribute so i haven't
been able to contribute in
whatever it's been almost 10 years now
but for anyone out there making less 140
grand if you don't have a 401k get your
ass involved with the roth ira
the flip side of that would get back to
peter thiel here is this is insane
you're talking about how they're maybe
capping what a roth ira could
possibly be a couple million bucks
when i read this i thought he had five
million in there and i was like oh damn
yeah how do you do that
it's five million five million it can't
be five billion five billion
in a roth ira and when you have a
contribution limit of apparently two
thousand dollars when this started in
1999
now the contribution limit is six grand
you're telling me he's somehow
he's put in he's maxed out as roth ira
and
built it up five billion dollars there's
clearly some tax
loophole going on here yeah like i get
it there's one side of the coin
you can do whatever you want you know if
that's how you want you know what for me
you know what
you know how i would use it here's how i
would use it i remember one time you
know uh you know
guys would go talking about this kid in
our school was like hey this guy took
ten thousand dollars of his dad's money
and he turned into 160 000 dollars
buying a oil stocks i was in 10th grade
right
and i was like oh my gosh whatever you
know i wish my dad would give me ten
thousand he's probably a crook he's
probably this he's probably that
everybody trashed this guy right years
later
i ran into him three years ago okay this
guy i don't know this kid like we're not
friends but i ran into him
three years ago i think he's in merchant
service today like five years ago
i said are you are you the guy i think
you are he says yeah i said i said
weren't you the kid
that your dad gave you 10 grand and you
got like 160 000 he says
how do you remember that was 20
something years ago i remember it
because i'm like
i'd love to have 160 000 here's what's
crazy
that story fired me up like [ __ ] i'd
love to have 160
000 versus some people are like look at
this guy all he cares about is money
look this is how i would use this if i
was biden today if i
really cared about people saving their
money i would say look
here's how big of an upside a roth ira
can have for you
as well he didn't do anything different
all he did is the investments he made
within the ira were into stocks you
could do it as well it was within
startups you can do this well it was
within ipos you can do many of those as
well
just get better and learn about how
money works but definitely start a roth
ira
i would drive the hell out of it and use
it as a way to motivate other people to
start a 200
a month roth ira patrick if you think
about it right at nine percent money is
going which
9.9 is the average of the s p for the
last 50 years
at that level money's going to double
roughly every seven years so
you know the doubling or compound it's
real like it's the eighth wonder of the
world it's really
magic when you think about compounding
so the question that i would ask people
is would you rather have 100 000
or a penny that doubles every day for a
month and at the end of a month
it's 5.3 million unless there's 31 days
of the month
it's 10.7 million dollars so the key is
it's the last double
the earlier you start the more you can
get and if money's going to double every
seven years how many doubles can you get
out of that
i say congratulations peter thiel more
power too buddy i hope that 5 billion
turns into 50 billion
and i hope more people go start doing
roth iras as well if they can
yeah let me tell you this isn't the last
we're hearing of this story the tax man
come if they're going to figure
out something of course they will
they're going to figure out some way
listen 5 million congratulations 5
billion
you've got some explaining nobody but no
no he has no explaining to do no
no no no this you see that's the mindset
of the majority in america it's a
problem adam
the government has explaining to do not
him he has
no way he didn't break any laws the
government created this loophole
he didn't do it he simply went and
followed the rules and the guidelines
that his accountant gave him and he's
got five billion
so the government has a lot of
explaining to do not peter thiel
unfortunately the media is bashing him
he didn't do nothing wrong
they're going to find some ways to come
out as an example unfortunately
they do it's a shame if they do that
back in 1999
this is the guy that start one of the
the paypal mafia founders and he also
started
what palantir he was initial yeah
investors in facebook
he's not he's in early on a monster now
here
correct me if i'm wrong i don't know if
you guys heard this barry and pat
he got 1.7 million shares of paypal
at .001 cents okay
1.7 million shares at less than a tenth
of a penny
now if you can do that too person out
there starting a roth ira
you could potentially have a billion
bucks in your ira good for
no one else has that access good no it's
not about no one else has that access
why don't you go network amongst the
right people go shake some hands and
meet those guys
now go network at the founders of paypal
everybody stop bro
stop what are you talking about yeah go
network with those guys
forget about him okay he went and hung
out with the paypal mafia which all
those guys came out being billionaires
right you know what i'm talking about
there's a bunch there's a bunch of them
it's like 40 names that we're talking
about read uh reed
but but here's here's what you could i
spoke at texas a m university i don't
know
seven years ago sixty six years ago
sometime like i remember that talk yeah
when i went to school you don't do drugs
you get high off life
i get high off life i don't like drugs i
remember thinking i remember coffee
coffee freaks me out i remember i think
being high
when i was watching that i was like holy
[ __ ]
this is what i'm doing wrong texas a m
but you know what i told
you here's what i told him i said forget
about meeting a peter thiel
go meet to peter thiel of your
university if i'm school there's a
different
camps group of camps that you want to be
you want to get close to some want to
give with the camps that are partying
and have all access to all the best
drugs and the women that's the camp they
want to be a part of
some go to the camps that are you know
playing video games that's a different
camp that you go to
some go to the camps that are you know
just be smoking weed and just getting
high and they're just doing whatever
they're doing some are the fraternities
some of the sports guys some of the and
but if there's a group of people
that are the idea guys that are saying
how about we go take over the world if
we were to come out with this
go in that camp yeah and then see what
happens ten years later
guess what more power to peter thiel and
those guys that got into that camp
elam by the way was 50th birthday
yesterday he turned 50 yes 50
50 years old yesterday i think he's
going to be i think he's going to do
something with his life
i think starting a little late resume
for the first 50 years i think he owns
the best resume i think he's got the
best resume
for the first female other than barry's
by the time he was 50. he had three
crystal balls already right there so
movies broadway yeah and a lot of other
things but but let's go let's go into
by the way speaking of peter thiel and
this roth ira have you ever read the
book the power of zero
yes what a book what a great book what a
book that was actually a book that
changed my
yeah which part which part of it of the
book the whole book i mean it's a it's a
thin little book
sizes ipad yeah uh i think ricky and i
my good friend ricky
aguilar and i were talking about the
other day but my story with this real
quick is i remember being
in vegas i was doing the the nalba tour
whatever
and uh they had this guest speaker i
could not tell you his name for the life
of me but i don't know
kai if you pull up the power of zero you
can david david mcknight there he is i
think he's from utah
and he talked about the power of zero
and the zero is this tax-free retirement
and he talked about how taxes are sure
to go up and
how the government budget is you know
completely
overloaded on social security and
medicare and medicaid and
if you want to have a tax for retirement
a big staple of that is a roth ira
and also the what is it the lerp life
insurance retirement plan yeah
but basically he broke down how you can
have a zero
a zero percent tax retirement and that
changed my life and i remember being
in the back of a room i don't know why
they do conferences in vegas because i
was sure as hell hungover
and i remember like popping my head up
being like what huh your time
and it just changed my life in the power
of zero and that's uh
a great example of what you can do with
the roth ira so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you